voilà on avait une page sociale peut
être encore un mot de ma une
manifestation pacifique est attendu à
bruxelles manifestation des pêcheurs
bretons étranglés par la baisse des
cours
page sociale qui nous amène tout droit
notre invité pierre bourdieu qui est
professeur de sociologie au collège de
france et qui a dirigé un livre qui
s'appelle la misère du monde
un livre de 800 pages avec une
cinquantaine de témoignages faisant tout
à fait ordinaires qui n'ont rien
d'héroïque qui ne sont pas ceux qu'on
voit à la télévision la misère du monde
c'est la misère de qui et c'est quelle
misère
il ya la grande misère qui est sur
laquelle on attire parfois l'attention
en particulier la télévision et puis il
y à la misère relative
nous avons voulu essayer de saisir à la
fois les formes extrêmes de la misère et
les formes les plus communes celles qui
sont visibles autour de nous dans cette
maison il y en a dans les universités il
y en avait dans les lycées et cette
petite misère que l'on ignore est
extrêmement important parce que elle
fait souvent écran la grande misère des
gens qui aujourd'hui parlent du monde
social les journalistes les
intellectuels etc sont souvent eux mêmes
en état de souffrance et cette
souffrance est grand la vision réelle du
monde donc il s'agissait pour nous de
faire parler justement un petit goût de
la méthode qui consiste en fait à
laisser parler les gens et à s'oublier
complètement est-ce que c'est facile
non c'est excellent balade est souvent
si avec un magnétophone mais voyons
comment vous faites pour vous extraire
de l'autre la difficulté est que il
s'agit à la fois
les effets et d'aider à s'exprimer tout
être à la fois extrêmement
soumis abandonné en quelque sorte de la
parole de se déconnecter août et en même
temps sans cesse en alerte pour assister
en quelque sorte la personne qui
s'exprime dans son travail d'expression
qui peut et qui doit dire ce livre est
ce que c'est un livre pour pour les
intellectuels ou pour les gens qui ont
des lettres bien sûr il est fait pour
les livres les gens qui vivent et
l'hymne mais nous voudrions qu'il soit
lu bien au delà et les nazis peu partout
nous je pense et je pense j'en ai des
attestations france qu'il est lisible
par tout le monde au fond on peut lire
ce livre comme une recueil de nouvelles
voies yonne un livre célèbre de
cervantès nouvel exemplaire je crois ce
sont des nouvelles exemplaires c'est à
dire ce sont des petites histoires de
gens ordinaires qui se révèle être très
extraordinaire en ces gens quand on les
regarde et quand on les entend comme il
faut je crois les entend on des
aventures tout à fait extraordinaire
autour de toutes petites choses par
exemple yade les conflits voisine à qui
se condense dans l'histoire de chats et
ce petit chat on est une sorte de 2,2
résumé mythique de des conflits qui
opposent une famille d'immigrés et
la voisine française voilà des petites
histoires pour les témoignages pierre
bourdieu dans votre post scriptum vous
écrivez ceci les gouvernants sont
prisonniers d'un entourage rassurant de
jeunes technocrates qui ignorent souvent
à peu près tout de la vie quotidienne de
leurs concitoyens et à qui rien ne vient
rappeler leur ignorance
qu'est ce que vous dites aux hommes
politiques avec ce livre on est en
période électorale le discours politique
n'a rien à voir avec ça qui va veut que
je pense que je pense qu'il ya des
hommes politiques qui ont le soupçon de
leur ignorance ou de leurs distances aux
réalités sociales
je pense qu'il y en a peu qui ont le
courage d'avouer cette ignorance
publiquement et pas s'ils pensent qu'il
serait disqualifiée alors que je pense
qu'ils se rendraient respectable bon et
je pense surtout que il se donnerait
quelques chances d'accéder enfin à ce
peuple qui prétendent représenter on
nous parle de démocratie en longueur de
temps il n'est pas certain que les gens
qui parlent pour les autres soit en est
à même de de dire ce qu'il en est
puisque monopolise la parole
alors justement que diriez-vous à
monsieur le pen quand vous dites que
ceux qui veulent voter le pen en fait
expriment une souffrance
je ne sais pas si j'aurai envie de lui
parler mais mais je crois que alors
qu'est-ce que vous dirigez l'avancé de
l'usurpateur de souffrance je lui dirai
que
il n'y a peut-être rien de pire que de
fonder succès sur l'exploitation la
souffrance des autres c'est une forme de
barbarie
est ce que ce livre intimiste pas du
tout pas du tout je pense par exemple la
réponse du jeune frère je crois en
témoigne je pense que faire accéder la
souffrance au discours la rendent
exprimable c'est d'abord la rassurer
avec soin sur elle-même
mais c'est aussi la rendent comique et
la transformer en revendications et je
pense que les revendications les plus
profonds ne sont pas du tout du tout où
les situent les hommes politiques et
même les porte-parole attitré d'aider
des gens qui souffrent pierre bourdieu
merci merci de votre intervention
on n'a qu'un conseil à donner à tous
ceux qui nous regardent y compris les
hommes politiques c'est de lire la
misère du monde la france parle et c'est
publié au seuil